[Music]
did you see this viral video bring today
a dangling spider-man scaring folks and
stir bugs but it looks like in the end
they all laughed they laughed after they
freaked out I love the reactions it's
all to promote the new spider-man
homecoming movie and the new Spidey Tom
Holland told us all about it last night
at the New York pranic a patina for us
the baristas are real so are all but one
of the customers and I have a brand
ekobrew for spider-man could have been
right out of the movie it's really cool
I see that was one of my good friends
Christo copes he was in the suit and
yeah that's an amazing video a lot of
fun Frannie cold brew spider-man the
location of Starbucks in Brooklyn New
York retrofitted with a fake ceiling and
a fake AC vent Chris Silcox one of three
Spidey stunt doubles in spider-man
homecoming is attached to a Kevlar cable
with spider-man creator Stan Lee
anonymously taking pictures from a
corner a pulley system lowers Chris to
the counter I jump really
I probably freaked out Tom in costume
actually went to a Starbucks while
shooting the film but kept it on the DL
with just his boots showing but this
appearance by his alter ego was a little
more in-your-face
[Music]
you